what does the first draft kind of look
like in terms of
what what kind of things do you plop
down oh so it'll be like let's suppose i
just read like you know some book called
the guillotine at work which was an
early book attacking lenin from the
narco communist perspective so it'll
just be like all the different quotes
like a paragraph here double space
another paragraph you know blah blah
so on and so forth whereas for other
sections where i wasn't just
using a book as research
there would be like talking about
mckinley getting shot like it's just me
writing the narrative
and that i could just pretty much copy
paste into the second draft by way of
advice would you give
that as advice is that a good way to do
it is that a very peculiar way your
brain no so this is this is actually
advice i feel comfortable giving to
people who are trying to write
uh
because it's just like with the gym
right if you did seven sets seven excuse
me reps last week and you did eight this
week it's psychologically motivating
because you're going the right direction
and the human mind extrapolates so
make sure tell yourself i'm gonna get a
page done today or two pages done
sit your ass on the computer you're not
allowed to get up to get those two pages
it doesn't matter if they look at
garbage
because if you have a 300 page first
draft
and it's crap
at least you have something to work with
and that's a big number
so if you're gonna the thing is since
the first draft is gonna be crap if
you're editing as you're right it's
gonna be extremely discouraging and it's
also trying to drive and then doing
reverse at the same time it's it's a
completely nonsensical way to do it get
it all out there don't look it over if
you have a great line put in your phone
and then add it to the the draft so
it'll be a complete slog but editing
that slog is gonna be a lot easier than
creating it to begin with and when you
see those disparate lines all laid out
on the page how difficult is it to
then start stitching it together do you
find that
when you look at a list of those things
the final product will look very
different yeah how will you actually use
those lines no i will use those lines
then i have a file called scraps so like
if the line's no longer used i put in my
scrap pile
i'd love to see what's in the scrap pile
okay yeah sure
one of the things i've been pulling
scraps is a lot of times when i was
earlier writing
i would have contemporary references
and i realized that that's bad because i
want the
the the reader to be in the past as the
present so if you're talking about let's
say 1901 and you're referring to obama
that screws people up so i had to pull
all those
you